this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream
[Music]
this is a basilisk a cross between a
chicken and a snake it's equipped with
deadly venom as it roams the swamps of
medieval poland it searches for its prey
sorry about that medieval zoology is
bizarre mostly because half the
creatures don't even exist and those
that do look very very strange i want to
take you on a journey highlighting the
weird and wild creatures of european
folklore a world where mythology and
biology blend together in this handy
field guide we'll see why you should
never pay full price for unicorn horns
and why this christian saint has the
head of a dog sit back relax and enjoy
it's gonna get weird
we start in the south of france with a
ferocious beast known as the tarasque
it's somewhere between a dragon and a
tortoise and looks a bit like bowser
from super mario now according to some
rumors the tarasque was the love child
between the biblical leviathan and a
creature known as a bonacon a bull-like
monster that shoots corrosive dung at
its enemies charming the taras habitat
is on the banks of rivers or in deep
caves and was known to swallow unwary
travellers that came too close according
to a medieval french chronicle saint
martha defeated one by sprinkling holy
water onto its head and then she wrapped
a rope around its neck she then led it
to a nearby village where it was clubbed
to death by the angry townsfolk for
centuries the people of tarascon have
held an annual festival commemorating
this heroic deed even today an effigy of
the monster is paraded around town and
beaten with sticks
a good place to look for medieval
monsters is in bestiaries encyclopedias
of all the known creatures in the world
real or imagined
this one the aberdeen bestiary is the
most exquisite around you can see all
kinds of familiar animals in its gilded
pages like these ones here but there are
some creatures like these that do not
exist my favorites however are the
real-life animals that are highly
inaccurate elephants in particular they
are often depicted with castles on their
backs it's likely that the illustrators
had never actually seen an elephant and
base their drawings entirely on
exaggerated descriptions offered by
travellers
now for some plant life
this is a goose tree yes a tree that
grows geese when ripe the eggs would
hatch and drop the chicks down to the
ground
unfortunately such a plant is not real
but the story behind this myth is
fascinating you see for a very long time
no one knew how geese reproduced as
between the roosting months of october
through to march they were simply
nowhere to be seen what people didn't
know is that these birds had migrated
across the atlantic to greenland and
north america land that was not yet
known to most europeans the myth sprung
up to explain what happened during these
months as it would be a long time yet
until the migratory patterns of these
birds were fully understood perhaps the
most majestic creature of all was the
griffin believed to be the king of
beasts it has the body of a lion with
the head and wings of an eagle in the
distant past people claim to own
physical remnants of such monsters this
is the so-called griffon claw of saint
cuthbert it was allegedly found in the
tomb of this northumbrian saint surely
this is irrefutable proof that griffins
once roamed the skies
well no not quite these are not gryffind
claws at all flip them around and
they're the horns of an ibex a type of
mountain goat
physical remains of mythical beasts
could fetch a high price on the market
especially as they are believed to be
magical
in 1577 tudor queen elizabeth the first
was believed to have bought a unicorn
horn to the tune of 10 000 pounds which
is worth around 2 million pounds in
today's money what she didn't know is
that there were in fact narwhal tusks
that had washed up on the shore of
greenland talk about being royally
swindled we're lucky today that all
kinds of knowledge are readily available
that's why this video is sponsored by
curiositystream curiositystream is an
online streaming service with a library
of fascinating documentaries think
netflix but for 100 non-fiction
storytelling there are plenty of
award-winning documentaries to go and
watch from history nature true crime and
more pretty much anything you can think
of and with a constantly expanding
library of exclusive shows there's
always something new
i've recently watched a series called
the biblical plagues
using historical evidence and
archaeological data it explores whether
the apocalyptic events from the book of
exodus may have actually happened if
you've enjoyed my videos in biblical
history then this one will be right up
your street you can stream their shows
onto any device and even watch them
offline so you can expand your horizons
on the go
if you use code hotelaga to sign up you
can access all of curiositystream's
online movies and shows for just 14.99
for the entire year head to the
description below to get started
thanks curiositystream ok back to the
video
taking to the high seas now this map of
scandinavia is positively brimming with
all kinds of strange marine life we have
giant kaiju sized lobsters off the coast
of scotland and near iceland we have a
so-called sea pig with eyes on its belly
over here it looks like these sailors
have made camp on the back of a whale
this little detail pops up in a number
of early illustrations and it pays
homage to the miraculous tales of saint
brendan and the biblical prophet jonah
both had unfortunate run-ins with large
sea creatures the prevalence of monsters
in maps like these reflect the fears the
early sailors had about traversing the
ocean fearsome sea monsters became a
plausible explanation why the sea was
able to claim the lives of so many souls
it wasn't just strange animals that
early explorers saw but people as well
in the travels of sir john mandeville a
fantastical travel memoir from 1357 the
titular explorer documents a strange
race of headless men
he described them as quote an ugly folk
without heads who have eyes in each
shoulder and that their mouths were
quote round like a horseshoe in the
middle of their chest
what he'd stumbled across were blemis
and sightings of these strange torso
folk stretch well back into antiquity
having first been described by roman
naturalist pliny the elder
they've often been found in decorated
maps existing at the margins of the
known world and although the name may
have come from a desert tribe in north
africa very little else is known about
the origin of these bizarre creatures
some have speculated that they could be
distorted descriptions of bonobos
relatives of chimpanzees i guess with
their chins tucked into their bodies the
mystery continues
along with the blemish the travels of
sir john mandeville describes a number
of other strange humanoids from monopods
who hop about on one foot to panotti who
possess long flappy ears that go down to
their toes but he also mentions a race
called cynocephaly aka dog people in a
number of world mythologies dog human
hybrids are a common occurrence most
famously anubis the egyptian god of the
underworld but you may be surprised to
know that they feature in medieval
christianity as well
take a look at this russian icon of
saint christopher you'll immediately
notice that he too has a canine face
why was this christian saint a werewolf
no but it's all to do with a very
amusing mistranslation you see the
original saint christopher was from the
biblical land of canaan and so is often
called saint christopher the canaanite
however early latin translators confused
the word kanan for the word for dog
canine so saint christopher the
canaanite became saint christopher the
canine ite it plays out in english the
same way as latin hence later
illustrations as far away as russia
sometimes depicted him as a dog human
hybrid i've saved the weirdest for last
the strangest of all medieval monsters
appear in the margins of illuminated
manuscripts they are collectively
referred to as grotesques and for good
reason they are marvelously hideous some
of my favorites appear in the lutteral
psalter an english book of psalms from
the 14th century these uniquely bizarre
monsters decorate the text and no one
quite knows why they're there could they
be religious allegories with long-lost
messages or are they there to entertain
amuse or frighten the readers whatever
they are they clearly inspired the
nightmarish paintings of hieronymus
bosch who included many of them in his
ghoulish hellscapes i did a video
exploring his disturbing artworks which
you can watch after this
arriving at the end of this field guide
we've covered a lot of legendary
creatures from the european middle ages
from tarasks to griffins blemis to goose
trees they are all wonderfully strange
and really give us an insight into how
medieval europeans understood the
natural world whilst we might be amused
by the inaccurate drawings of elephants
today remember so little of the
environment was known back then and so
the lines between reality and myth were
blurry even with the first truly
scientific classification of animals by
carl linnaeus many of these mythical
creatures were put into an appendix a
sort of honorable mentions list nowadays
the natural world is more fact than
fantasy but it's still amazing and worth
protecting and with so many undiscovered
species still out there who knows
perhaps some of these beasts really do
exist
[Music]
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this one and thank you
curiositystream for reaching out to
sponsor this video as of this upload the
channel has recently passed half a
million subscribers i'm honestly
astounded by this i just wanted to thank
you again so much for watching my videos
oh and on that note if you haven't
already why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way season
3 has just begun so stick around for
more
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye